on the front line of a new viral
epidemic there's no room for error
carefully doctors in Wuhan put on their
suits and masks their best chance of
protection against the potentially
deadly coronavirus the sickness that
started in their city has built in
strength and seeped out sending
infection rates in China rocketing 50
percent in just 24 hours from our
observation the disease can be spread
during the incubation period the
incubation period lasts for 10 days the
shortest is one day the longest is 14
days this is very different from SARS to
emergency hospitals are now being built
to deal with the sick but the spread of
coronavirus is accelerating and verified
pictures appear to show hospital wards
overwhelmed patients filling the
corridors in others doctors seem at
breaking point to try to ease the strain
the militaries sent in reinforcements
health workers from the People's
Liberation Army and as China struggles
to contain the disease millions of
people are under some level of lockdown
the usually busy streets of Wuhan are
now eerily quiet the millions of
residents cannot leave so they've shut
themselves away in the hope of staying
safe one British man who asked to remain
anonymous told us people are terrified
it's pretty scary I mean we're all kind
of just locked up in doors no one's
leaving their apartment unless it's an
emergency or to get some supplies but we
all fall in contact so breathing in
behind our in contact through we chances
though we can always if there's any new
information we can share that with each
other in pretty poor and while the
majority of infections are still in
Wuhan coronavirus has crossed borders
Canada the US France Australia and
Thailand
among those treating patients with the
virus is likely to grow bigger still yes
the Chinese government and public health
authorities have implemented some very
stringent method measures in China but
we're probably still seeing the upward
growth in cases and with more than 2,000
patients still awaiting tests this is
just the start the US and Japan will
send planes to Wuhan to get some of
their citizens out there is no such
escape route for Chinese residents
living at the epicenter Siobhan Robbins
Sky News